vous avez annoncé vouloir un débat au
parlement sur l'immigration mais ce
n'est pas un débat que les français
attendent ce sont des mesures concrètes
pour réduire l'immigration
quelle crédibilité avez vous alors que
votre gouvernement a battu l'ensemble
des records en 2018 votre proposition de
quotas d'immigration ne concerne que
l'émigration économique soit 13 % des
arrivées légal oubliant les autres
portes d'entrée en particulier
l'immigration familiale
il n'y a pas de droits de l'homme a
émigré dans le pays de son choix c'est
aux français de décider qui entre qui
résident en france et c'est donc alors
représentants de voter des plafonds
annuels d'immigration
la réalité c'est que nos capacités
d'intégration sont dépassés puisque vous
êtes incapable de limiter les entrées
depuis deux ans les républicains font
des propositions concrètes pour réduire
l'immigration interdire la
régularisation des étrangers entrés
illégalement conditionner l'accès aux
prestations sociales à trois années de
cotisation limiter le regroupement
familial remontant plafond de ressources
supprimer le droit du sol pour les
immigrés illégaux déterminer l'aide au
développement retour des sans papiers
dans leur pays d'origine
monsieur le premier ministre êtes vous
prêt à enfin écoutez votre position et
appliquer ces mesures de bon sens pour
finalement réduire l'immigration en
france les agriculteurs et les
viticulteurs ont aujourd'hui besoin de
la solidarité nationale
sinon ils mettront la clé sous la porte
vous avez annoncé que l'état va déclarer
en situation de catastrophe naturelle et
de calamités agricoles ces départements
c'est indispensable mais monsieur le
ministre c'est loin d'être suffisant
nos agriculteurs sont les poumons de nos
territoires
mais s'il c'est ouf ils ont donc besoin
que nous leur venue en aide
monsieur le ministre vous avez affirmé
qu'aucun agriculteur ne mettra soulac la
clé sous la porte
eca phénomène exceptionnel mesures
exceptionnelles de l'état or pour que
votre promesse soit nabeul l'état doit y
consacrer des moyens
le département de la drôme et la région
auvergne rhône-alpes vont apporter leur
soutien à l'état d'apporter la ciel que
la politique publique qui est la plus en
échec aujourd'hui c'est celle de la
santé cet échec
cette crise prend plusieurs formes celle
d'abord de la résignation de nos
services d'urgences hospitalières 120
services d'urgence sont actuellement en
grève illimitée
c'est du jamais vu c'est l'expression
d'une détresse qui est tout à la fois
l'exploit
de la fréquentation qui trouve sa cause
en amont dans l'insuffisance de prise en
charge au niveau de la médecine de ville
et puis des mesures budgétaires mises en
oeuvre dans vos adresses où l'on décide
de fermer des lits de gérer des crédits
de faire attendre des projets comme
celui de l'extension des urgences de
l'hôpital de lisieux
les personnels des urgences ont pris sur
eux des années face à une telle
dégradation de leurs conditions
d'exercice
aujourd'hui ils n'en peuvent plus ce
n'est pas les 70 millions d'euros que
vous avez annoncée en catastrophe en fin
de semaine dernière qu'ils vont y
changer grand chose
rendez aux hôpitaux les moyens retiré
depuis cinq ans plus tôt que nous
soucier à ne pas trop brusquer nos
détenus ne pensez vous pas qu'il est de
notre devoir de protéger nos gardiens
les seules mesures que vous proposez
sont de les équiper de gillet par l'âme
de protège cou ou de caméra embarquée
quand allez vous à vous attaquer aux
causes plutôt que d'essayer tant bien
que mal de parer aux effets ainsi madame
la ministre ma question sera la suivante
pour éviter que cela ne se reproduise
une fois de plus et pour mettre fin aux
innombrables agressions quotidiennes de
nos gardiens
quelles mesures prendre et vous enfin
pour garantir le retour de l'autorité de
l'état dans nos prisons et assurer la
sécurité de ceux qui chaque jour se
dévoue à servir notre pays
aujourd'hui nos infrastructures et nos
moyens de transport doivent être plus
propre plus durable plus connectés mais
hélas le projet de loi ne répond pas à
la question essentielle du financement
le déficit prévisionnel de lafitte
s'élèvent à plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros pour 2019 je vous
rappelle que les recettes de l'athéisme
pe pour 2019 seront de 37 milliards
d'euros mais que seuls 1,2 servira à
l'investissement dans les
infrastructures de communication
dans ces conditions comment entretenir
les réseaux routiers fluviaux
ferroviaire dont on a tant besoin et en
particulier dans le milieu rural
comment mener à bien les grands
chantiers indispensables à la
modernisation de notre pays
en 2018 5989 mineurs isolés ont été
arrêtés par la préfecture de police à
paris et en petite couronne
il s'agit essentiellement de garçons
nous savons que la situation est
complexe
les mineurs étrangers
ce sont d'abord des enfants et ses
enfants sont avant tout des victimes
avant d'être des délinquants
je souhaiterais savoir si le
gouvernement entend mettre en oeuvre un
cadre d'action national pour aider ces
jeunes en errance et pour lutter contre
la délinquance qui en découlent grise et
colère pour la filière betterave sucre
éthanol française l'annoncé de la
fermeture de deux sucreries haqqani et
d'huile par le groupe allemand chez du
caire voici plus de deux mois mais cette
filière en danger il est inadmissible
que vous ne répondez pas aux
sollicitations d'audience
que vous ont adressé dès le 29 mai les
élus et les responsables de la filière
[Musique]